Well, good morning church.
It's great to see you today.
Uh, be together to worship today.
Uh, my name is John, one of the pastors here.
If you're new to our church, we'd love to meet you.
Uh, either come introduce yourself up here at the front
afterwards, or the new here area in the lobby just to get
to meet you and help you connect
to our church as best we can.
Uh, as we get into it today,
jealousy can make you do some crazy things, can't it?
Jealousy can lead someone
to create a fake social media account strictly
to flame someone who is their, their perception
to be more popular or more athletic or smarter
or whatever it is than they are.
Or it can lead someone to physical violence.
As they think about this comparison trap
that they're stuck in, it can actually lead to violence
or as the story goes, two shopkeepers were bitter rivals
and their stores were directly across the street from each
other, and they would spend each day like comparing
and keeping track of each other's business.
If one got a customer, he would smile slyly at the other one
and triumph over his rival.
Well, one night an angel appeared to one
of the shopkeepers in a dream
and he said, I will give you anything you ask,
but know that I will give your rival twice as much.
Would you be rich? Well, you can be rich,
but he will be twice as wealthy.
If you would be healthy. Well, you can be healthy,
but you know that his life will be longer
and more fulfilling.
So what is your desire?
Well, the shopkeeper thought, he frowned, he
pro pondered for a moment.
He said, well, here's my request.
Strike me blind in one eye.
Half of you got that one. So let me tell the other half.
I'll give you double. I'll give
him double what I give you, right?
So one, okay, anyway, all right. Whew.
Uh, that's why I don't start with jokes ever.
Like that's just the way it is.
I don't, okay, so jealousy can cause you
to do some crazy things.
I'll change that for the second service.
Um, but it's not just with relationships
or with stuff or with business.
It doesn't just that way make you do some crazy stuff.
It can even happen spiritually.
Jealousy can creep into our lives. This is with pastors too.
We can get this way. You can see like when God's hand is
evidently on someone's life, like we have a choice,
how we respond to that, we can be jealous.
We can try to cut them down.
We can just, just try to, to
eliminate their influence somehow and,
and just to make ourselves feel better.
We can resist what God is evidently doing,
or we can say, Hey, you know what?
I'm gonna get on board with what God's doing
and I'm gonna support it.
We have that choice. And
that's actually the stark contrast we're gonna see today
in one Samuel 18, as, as God's presence is
now clearly with David in the narrative, We're gonna watch
how different people respond to that in various ways.
And it's gonna challenge us to see whether we're going
to sync up with what God is doing
with his work in the world, even through other people,
other churches, other ministries,
or are we going to resist God's work as well?
And so, God, we need you towards this.
We need you to, to challenge us, to change us in our hearts.
Every one of us in this room, every one of us watching needs
something done in our hearts to more
and better align with your purpose in the world,
with your work in the world.
So God lead us to that. We need you, holy Spirit.
That's your work in our hearts through your word.
And we pray that that would happen today for your glory in
name, amen.
So if you're not already there,
take your copy of God's word.
Turn with me to one Samuel,
chapter 18, one Samuel 18.
We're gonna take all 30 verses of this together,
continuing our series through this book, verse
by verse in this.
And, and so we're into chapter 18.
And what we just saw was David had
finally come on the scene.
He defeated Goliath.
He'd been anointed as the next king of Israel.
But watch how people responded to David.
Now follow along
and read the whole chapter to give us the picture
of it as we go forward.
As soon as David had finished speaking to Saul, the soul
of Jonathan was knit to the soul of David
that Jonathan's David's or Saul's son.
Jonathan loved David as his own soul, and Saul took him.
David that day, would not let him return
to his father's house.
Then Jonathan made a covenant with David
because he loved him as his own soul.
Jonathan stripped himself of the robe that was on him
and gave it to David, his armor, even his sword,
his bow, his belt.
And David went out
and was successful wherever Saul sent him so
that Saul set him over the men of war.
And this was good in the sight of all the people
and also in the sight of Saul's
servants As they were coming home.
When David returned from striking down the
Philistine, that was Goliath.
The women came out of all the cities of Israel singing
and dancing to meet King Saul with tambourines
and songs of joy with musical instruments.
And the women sang to one another as they celebrated.
Saul has struck down his thousands
and David his 10 thousands.
And Saul was very angry, and this saying displeased him.
And he said, they've ascribed to David 10 thousands to me.
They've ascribed thousands. What more can he have?
But the kingdom? And Saul ied David from that day on
the next day, a harmful spirit from God rushed upon Saul
and he raved within his house while David was playing the
liar, as he did day by day.
And Saul had a spear in his hand. And ha.
And Saul hurled the spear for he thought,
I'll pin David to the wall.
But David evaded him twice and Saul was afraid of David
'cause the Lord was with him, and he had de,
but he had departed from Saul.
So Saul removed him from his presence, made him a commander
of a thousand, just a small army commander,
and he went out and came in before the people.
And David had success in all his undertakings,
for the Lord was with him.
And when Saul saw that he had great success,
he stood in fearful awe of him.
But all Israel and Judah loved David for he went out
and came in before them.
Then Saul said to David, here's my elder daughter, Meab,
I'll give her to you for a wife.
Only be valiant for me and fight the Lord's battles.
For Saul. Thought, well, let not my hand be against him,
but let the hand of the Philistines be against him.
And David said to Saul, who am I then? Who are my relatives?
My father's clan in Israel
that I should be son-in-law to the king?
But at the time when Mirab Saul's daughter should have been
given to David, she was given to Adriel, the
Meite for a wife.
Now, Saul's other daughter, McCall loved David.
And they told Saul and the thing pleased him.
And Saul thought, okay, let me give her to him
that she may be a snare for him, that the hand
of Philistines may be against him.
And so Saul said to David, A second time,
you shall now be my son-in-law.
And Saul commanded his servants speak to David in private,
say, behold, the king has delight in you.
All his servants love you.
Now then become the king's son-in-law.
And Saul's servants spoke those words in the ears of David.
And David said again, does it seem to you a little thing
to become the king's son-in-law?
Since I'm a poor man, I have no reputation.
And the servants of Saul told him that what David had said.
And, and then verse 25, then Saul said, okay,
thus you shall say back to David,
the king desires no bride price except 104 skins
of the Philistines, that he may Aven be avenged
of his king's enemies.
Now, Saul thought to make David fall
by the hand of the Philistines.
And when his servants told David these words,
it pleased David well to be the king's son-in-law.
And before the time had expired, David Arosen went along
with his men and killed 200 of the Philistines.
David brought the foreskins, which were given in full number
to the king, that he might become the king's son-in-law.
And Saul gave him his daughter McCall for a wife.
But when Saul saw
and knew the Lord was with David, that McCall,
Saul's gutter loved him, Saul was even more afraid of David.
So Saul was David's enemy continually.
And then the commanders of the
Philistines came out to battle.
And as often as they came out,
David had more success than all the servants of Saul, so
that his name was highly esteemed.
Alright, so we look at the themes of this chapter,
we're gonna see a couple of those themes,
and here we see it's clear that in one Samuel 18,
David was enjoying God's success
evident throughout this passage that David,
it was enjoying God's success.
We actually see that word success four
times in this chapter.
It shows up in verse five.
David was successful wherever Saul sent him.
He became a leader among the army.
Verse 14, David had success in all his undertakings.
Verse 15, Saul saw David's success.
And then verse 30, the very end,
David had more success than all the servants of Saul.
And that word means what you think. It means success.
He was victorious. He was doing what he planned to do.
See, we've been building to this plateau for weeks now.
We saw Saul repeatedly
declining in his spiritual health
and David continually being elevated to the throne.
There was growth happening, there was progress happening,
but it's clear what's what God was doing here.
He was fulfilling the promise he'd made to Samuel,
he'd made to Saul.
Even that Saul had been rejected from being the king.
God was bringing that transition about,
and he was proving it to everyone
by this young new leader named David,
giving him success in everything he attempted.
God was saying, here's the man. Yet we read through that.
It almost seems too good to be true.
Like, like the old mythological God, Midas, you know that
where everything he touched turns to gold.
It seems like that's David's life right now. He can't lose.
He can't have anything but success.
It's just going everywhere. It should.
But notice what we see the narrator be very careful
to say here he says,
why David was so successful.
Did you see why? Look again at verse 12,
Saul was afraid of David because the Lord was with him,
but had departed from Saul.
Now, verse 14, David had success in all his undertakings,
for the Lord was with him.
Verse 28 actually says the same thing.
The reason the reason David enjoyed God's success is
because he experienced God's presence.
He was enjoying God's success
because he experienced
God's presence in his life.
Again, the contrast between Saul
and David could not be clearer here
it says it very clearly.
The spirit of God had removed from Saul
and the spirit of God was all over.
David. You see that?
That verse said it, it removed from Saul, yet was on David.
Now it's a different world back then.
Remember today the Holy Spirit indwells a believer from the
moment of salvation securing them for eternity.
But back then, before Jesus, back then, there was this,
this measure of the spirit coming
and going on people at certain times for certain reasons.
And often the spirit of God would leave someone
because of their sin, because of the issues in their life.
Well, we saw that with Saul clearly here.
But now we learn about David throughout his life,
whether things were good or bad.
David had an experiential knowledge of God's presence.
The presence of God was the difference
maker in David's life.
Now, there was even a further result
of God's presence on David's life.
What we see with David here is that he began
to receive other people's loyalty, like
because the spirit of God was on him.
He was bringing success to David.
He had all these military
battles and all the things worked well.
But he also began to receive other people's loyalty.
Again, there's a shift happening from Saul being the king
and everybody loyal to the king, to David becoming the king.
And the shift of loyalty is even happening in Saul's family.
It's happening elsewhere, but it's even in Saul's family.
We saw it right away at the beginning of the chapter, right?
Saul's son, Saul's son, Jonathan gives his loyalty to David.
Jonathan became David's best friend.
He supported protected David for years.
We'll see it throughout this whole book of first Samuel
Saul, his son Jonathan,
who would've been the heir apparent to Saul being the king.
Jonathan would've been the next one. He's loyal to David
in spite of his king father.
He's protecting, supporting this new king.
Now, some people have tried to make Jonathan
and David's relationship more than
what the text actually allows for that to happen.
So don't read into this in any way,
but what I want you to see is how deep
Jonathan's loyalty was to
David.
Like did you see it? There was a soul
level commitment there.
There were four times in just three verses.
The word soul is used by Jonathan,
like they were brothers more than they were just friends.
Jonathan aligned his life with David.
He saw the anointing of God on David's life,
and he says, I'm with you.
And listen, I, I fear that most
of us have no idea what that's like.
I To have a friend like that.
I read a study from 2021, so it's a few years old.
I don't know if it's gotten better or worse,
but it said at the time, 76%
of men don't have a close trusted friend.
Like three fourths of men don't have a man in their life
that they could talk to about anything.
Like no topic off limits, just I need somebody.
Three-fourths don't have that.
Like that's an epidemic level concern, isn't it?
And so why is friendship dying?
Because our culture, here's, here's a couple reasons.
Our culture has sexualized everything.
So it's hard for two men
or two women to be really close friends without suspicion.
We're also so ruggedly individualistic in our lives.
Even though God, one of the first things he ever said was,
it's not good for man to be alone.
We love living our lives by ourselves.
Listen, there is no such thing
as a lone ranger Christian, right?
You, you can't be that. That's an oxymoron
because Christian implies family and connection.
You can't be isolated as a Christian. You need each other.
I need you, you need me. We need each other.
But along with that, we're not only
individualistic, we're also just too busy.
We're too busy for friendships now to invest time
and energy and resources in someone else and them and you.
Does that cost you something? Yes.
But the rewards are immeasurable.
When you really have someone like that,
like so can, can we as the church champion the resurrection
of friendships, like to really have people in our lives
that, that we, we are not too busy to pray, to listen,
to care, to help.
Nobody can walk alone.
Like that's, that's a dangerous thing to walk alone.
Can we be different? By the way, the church will be known,
Jesus said, we'll be known by our love for one another, not
by our great worship services or our big buildings,
or a lot of like, how are they gonna know us love?
And if we don't love each other that way,
like what are we doing?
So can we champion this Saul's son, Jonathan
showed us, but it wasn't just Saul's son,
so it was his family, right?
It was also his daughter, right?
It was in Saul's family, the king's family who are aligning
with this new King Saul's daughter.
Verse 20, Saul's daughter, McCall says, loved David.
It's a deep word right there. She saw God's hand on David.
She said, I'm gonna align with him.
Now, it didn't hurt that he was ruddy and handsome.
I'm sure that was probably a added benefit,
but she saw God's hand, right?
But again, it's amazing. Even in Saul's own household,
they recognized the hand of God on David's life.
And they said, I'm with him now,
which drove Saul even more mad.
Yet it wasn't just his family, it was bigger than that.
Did you see throughout chapter 18,
you saw it was also Saul's nation who threw its loyalty
behind David, his son, his daughter, and even his nation.
Verse five said, David being the leader of the army
was good in the sight of all the people
and also in the sight of Saul's servants.
Verse seven records, the women's song, right?
Remember that Saul's exploits compared
to David's greater exploits.
Verse 16, all Israel and Judah loved David.
Even the very end, verse 30, his name was highly esteemed.
Like this is the picture we're getting.
And you remember the chart.
We're gonna put it up here again.
This is the chart we've shown throughout the whole cha
whole series here.
You see that as Saul is declining in his popularity,
David is increasing in his popularity.
We're about at that place where those two lines hit.
David is growing and Saul is declining.
One's up, one's down.
That's where we're at in this scene now.
So his daughter, his son, his nation,
they were all turning towards Saul.
There was one person in this whole thing
that was not happy about all of that.
Obviously it would be Saul, right?
And from this point forward,
we already saw it here consistently.
Saul began to resist God's purpose.
We saw it here. We'll see it
throughout the rest of the book.
Saul knew this was God's plan.
This was God's purpose for David to be the king.
And yet Saul resisted.
I'm gonna read back through a couple spots in chapter
18 verses eight and nine.
Saul was very angry. This displeased him.
He said, they've ascribed to David 10 thousands. To me.
They've ascribed thousands. What more can he have?
But the kingdom and Saul ied David, from that day on,
there's jealousy all over that, right?
And it makes you do crazy things.
Watch this verses 10 and 11.
Next, the next day, a harmful spirit from God
rushed upon Saul.
He raved within his house while David was playing the liar,
as he did day by day, that used to calm Saul down.
And Saul had his spear in his hand,
and Saul hurled the spear for, he thought,
I'm gonna pin David to the wall.
I'm gonna kill him this time. But David evaded him twice.
That's what jealousy did to Saul.
Verse 15 says, Saul stood in fearful awe of David.
That's not a good word. There he was scared,
terrified to lose the kingdom to this new king.
But you have to remember this.
This is why we don't read these passage in isolation.
The whole thing fits together. Saul already knew
that David was gonna be the next king.
He knew that was God's plan. He knew that was God's purpose.
And so Saul had a choice.
He could have humbled himself, embraced that plan,
got outta David's way.
But what did he do instead? He tried
to set up David's death twice.
He tried to kill David twice.
Again, though the cumulative effect of all of it was that.
Verse 29 says, Saul was even more of afraid of David.
So Saul was David's enemy continually till the end
of Saul's life, these two anointed
ones are at odds.
And listen, that's, that's one aspect of this that each
of us need to consider today as well.
How can we resist God's purpose in the world around us?
What are ways that we can hinder God's work?
God will do his work. God.
God will accomplish his plan,
but we can get in the way, have to
be removed so that God can do what he's gonna do.
How can we do that? 'cause again,
Saul could have humbly submitted to this process,
and most likely we don't know this for sure,
but most likely Saul would've had a
place in David's kingdom.
Jonathan did. But John, the son of Saul, he humbled himself,
said, I'm with you, David,
and had a place Saul probably could have as well,
had a place to serve in David's kingdom.
But rather than releasing his selfish grip on his
cherished role as King
Saul tried to prevent David from becoming king.
And in the process, he destroyed himself with jealousy.
I mean, Saul, think about it.
He'd been called to such a high position.
He'd been given such great abilities.
But then he used that position and those abilities to oppose
and to persecute the Lord's anointed.
He could have used that position for such good,
but he instead used it to try to hinder the pro.
And really, he did hinder the progress
of God's kingdom for many years.
If he would've just stepped away, David would've stepped in.
And the kingdom of God
through Israel there would have just grown and expanded.
But years and years of trial and trouble came from this.
Listen, it's similar, similar for us today.
Every time we place our own ambitions,
our own selfish desires, our own goals
above what God is doing
or what God wants to do, we are just like Saul right here.
Instead, we should celebrate what God is doing, right?
Like even if it's not the way that we would've chosen it
to go, even if it's happening
through someone else,
we should encourage it.
We should celebrate it.
Even if our lives don't look just like the plan
that we had lined up for ourselves.
Can we trust that God is still working through it?
Or are we gonna get in the way
and we're gonna hold onto something?
We're gonna, I
asked, I've asked this question.
I've had this question asked to me.
We pray for revival within the American church, right?
We want God to blow the doors off churches and save people
and draw people back to we.
We pray for that. We want that.
The question was asked, what if
that happened in the church down the street?
Would we still celebrate it?
We should, but would we?
Right? Like we pray for that, but
'cause we want it here, what if God does it
through someone else and we see God do amazing things?
Are we gonna celebrate it, encourage it, champion it, pray
for it, support it like that.
That's, that's where, where jealousy and selfishness
and greed and distraction, all of that stuff can be means
by which we resist God's purpose.
We work against what he's trying to do in us
and what he's trying to do around us.
That's church stuff. But but even think
about inside our lives.
If it's not the way we thought,
if it's not the way we want it,
God's still working through that.
Are we going to resist it?
Are we going to say, all right, I'm in.
I don't understand it. It's not the way I wanted it,
but I got, I got it.
Submit. I'm going to love you. I'm going to follow you.
Because here's what we should want more than anything.
We should want to receive God's pleasure, right?
Like, like we should want to receive
God's pleasure.
That's the the most important thing
that we see in all of this.
The, just think about sin for a second.
Sin is breaking God's commands
as we rebel against God's authority.
What it is, and listen to this, it's in the Lord's prayer.
We all pray, right? It's some point in our lives.
Sin is saying, my kingdom come, my will be done.
Is God gonna bless that perspective? No.
But what we saw in David's life is
what happens when we do please him.
When we do align with his purposes, his will be done,
his purposes on the earth in our lives.
When we align with that, what we get is blessing.
We get blessing from that.
Now, as soon as I say that, I feel like I have to caveat it
because our world, even the church world at large has said,
what that means then is
that when God's pleasure pours out on those who love you,
that means that all of life is going
to be up into the right.
Like it's all gonna be successful.
It's gonna look like Midas touch David over here.
Everything's gonna go well.
You're gonna get that job,
you're gonna get that relationship.
You're all that's gonna work.
You're gonna be healthy, you're gonna be wealthy.
Everything's gonna work for you.
That's what God's blessing entails.
That's a problem for the rest
of the chapters that we're gonna go into.
And for Samuel, because what we'll see is that David
actually has to suffer, Even though God is with him,
he walks through really difficult seasons,
even though God is with him.
But what we know is that in the end,
because of God's pleasure on you,
because it was on Jesus in your place,
God's pleasure was fully on him.
If you are in him, that means you have God's blessing.
And it may not be now, but it certainly will be later.
Because Jesus not only had God's blessing in life,
he had God's blessing in death
and in resurrection, which means you get it as well.
And so there is an eternal blessing
on the other side of this.
But that's the point I'm trying to make here, is
that in the moment, it may not feel like you're being
blessed by God.
I I love Hebrews 11 in the New Testament.
It's a great example of this.
We often refer to it as the hall of faith.
And it talks about those who had faith in God,
Who had assurance even though they couldn't see Jesus
or they couldn't look back
and see Jesus like we can, that they were saved
by their faith, just as much faith in God
that he was going to redeem.
But verse six, in Hebrews 11 says, they believed
because whoever would draw near
to God must believe that he exists.
And that he rewards those who seek him.
That's why they did it. Because they knew he was God.
They believed in him and they knew he was going
to reward those who seek him.
And and throughout Hebrews 11, many of the illustrations,
it gives portray rewards.
Abraham got a land, Moses got a victory.
Sarah got a baby. The people got the land.
Rahab, she got life when everyone else got death.
And then listen to this, it says,
many others conquered kingdoms,
enforce justice, obtained promises.
Stop the mouse of lions, quenched the power of fire,
escape the edge of the sword.
Were made strong out of weakness, became mighty in war.
Put foreign armies to flight, received back their dead
by resurrection.
Like that stuff is what we would celebrate
and feel like, man, look, the blessing of God is on them.
It's all great. We love championing that kind of stuff.
Yet we often stop there and we miss what's next.
'cause the scripture doesn't actually stop
or pause even right there.
It just continues explaining the
blessings, faith brings.
Watch this. Some were tortured,
refusing to accept release so
that they might rise again to a better life.
Others suffered mocking and flogging
and even chains and imprisonment.
They were stoned. They were sawn in two.
They were killed with a sword.
They went about in skins of sheep
and goats, destitute, afflicted, mistreated
of whom the world was not worthy.
Wandering about in deserts and mountains and in dens
and caves of the earth.
That's a pretty jarring difference, isn't it?
Between what we saw, what seemed really good
to all of a sudden now this seems really, really bad.
Well, here's the point. It simply means that we cannot link
God's pleasure on us merely to having a comfortable life.
'cause you know what else Hebrews 11 says?
It says none of them,
whether they're in this first category,
the things really easy, or the things that were really hard,
none of them actually received the things
promised from God because they
were all pre Christ.
They, they were all pre Jesus.
So it says what they were looking for,
what they were waiting for.
Hebrews 1116 says, is a better country,
a heavenly one, a better life?
'cause they knew that that place, that country was
where they would actually experience the full blessing
and pleasure of God.
Now, it's limited here. We might get glimpses of it here.
Things might go well, like when you have a baby
or you, you get that job.
Like things do go well at times.
But things here still can be hard.
Even when we live by faith. Remember job
Like The godliest man who may have ever lived
scraping boils with pottery.
That doesn't mean listen. If you're experiencing that,
if you experience that because of your faith,
that doesn't mean God's not good.
That doesn't mean that God has abandoned you.
It just means your eyes better be on something better,
on something more eternal.
Because This is limited.
You can lose this things can go south really fast.
It must be on something more where full blessing
will be yours because of the life, death,
and resurrection of Jesus Christ in your place.
That He's overcome death. He's overcome this world.
All the things that would go bad that would cause pain,
the persecution, the struggle, all that.
He's overcome it all. And the victory in Christ means we
have resurrection in him as well.
And that blessing will come.
He had God's full blessing and he will forever.
We can join in that.
Like that's What we must
pers must have that perspective.
So until that time comes, until he does come back
to what do we have, the perspective in our lives.
That's why we must remember
why David experienced what he experienced in chapter 18.
Why did he have God's blessing and pleasure?
Why was it because his focus in all of life was
to rest in God's presence?
He had success. He experienced God's blessing on his life.
He had those things, yes.
But his focus, his priority was to rest in God's presence.
That was the difference maker for David.
Everybody said it. Everybody saw it.
That was, and listen, it's no different for us today.
God's presence in your life is the difference maker
for you and me today.
And that concept, this is what we need to see with David.
That concept of God's presence in his life was not just some
abstract concept.
Like he just kind of felt, yeah, God's presence is here.
It was not really abstract for him.
It had an impact daily on his life.
And everyone could see it, right? Saul saw it.
Saul's children saw it. The nation saw it.
They're like, man, God's hand is on David.
God's presence is with David. So here's the question.
Is your life noticeably different
because the presence of God is on you?
Believer the presence of God is in you.
Is your life noticeably different?
Has has something changed to
where people look at you like, man, what?
What? What's going on here?
And they're drawn to you or,
or even the question here further,
are some people even afraid of you
because of the power of God flows through you.
That's what we saw here right now.
Now, listen, I'm not talking about people being afraid
of you just because you're some odd duck.
And in every conversation you throw a
Jesus juke in there somehow.
Like that's where people are scared.
Like here he comes again.
Like you know, you know those conversations
where you're like, oh, okay, you got your ears pierced.
That's cute. Jesus was pierced for our transgressions.
Like, that's weird. Okay? Don't, don't do that.
No, don't do. I'm talking about,
I'm talking about Saul, right?
Saul resisted God's purpose.
He was actually afraid of David. Think about that.
It should have been the other way around, right?
David should have been afraid of Saul
because this, this king Saul, he had a troubling spirit.
He tried to kill David twice.
He was the one with the upper hand.
He had the powerful king figure all the support he needed.
He could have got a servant do anything he wanted.
David should have been afraid of Saul.
But what was true, Saul was afraid of David.
Saul was afraid of David. Why?
Because of God's presence on David.
Listen, if you are faithful to the Lord, if you are,
if you are resting in God's presence
through his word, through prayer,
and you're resting in, you're dwelling,
you're abiding in God's presence in your life,
and you see this is the most important thing, you can know
that God is with you, no matter your whatever, your face,
your life will look different.
Your life will noticeably show that something God is doing.
He's working in your life
and in spite of the hostility in the world,
and often contrary to what it might appear to be on the
outside, even your
enemies will be afraid of you.
Again, it might not look like it
Because You might be taking shots right now
as you're facing, but even at the core of who they are,
the enemies will be afraid of you.
The devil sure is right, the the devil.
Why do you think he's coming after you so hard?
Listen, if he's not, first of all, you should be worried
because then you're not doing anything for God.
The devil's not worried about you.
But if he is coming at you hard,
why is he trying to derail you?
Distract you, destroy you. Why?
Because he can't stand God's presence on your life.
He can't stand God's presence in you believer.
And so rejoice in that.
Rejoice in the fact that you don't boast
that somehow the strengths in you to overcome him.
No, rejoice and rest in the fact that
that strength you have comes from outside of you.
It comes from Yahweh, and he's the one working through you.
And the devil is terrified
because it's not your strength.
It's God's strength,
and that is what makes all the difference and your life
and through you in the world.
That's what makes all the difference.